you
far from our home planet of earth past
Mars the asteroid belt and Jupiter over
1.2 billion kilometres from Earth we
find the majestic ringed planet Saturn
at about 83 times the surface area of
Earth Saturn is a gas giant with such
notable features as five hundred meter
per second wind speeds and its trademark
north polar hexagon and vortex orbiting
around the planet are 62 known moons as
well as innumerable moonlets too small
to be considered real moons among these
hundreds of satellites is one of the
largest and most complex unmanned
interplanetary spacecraft ever built
it's called Cassini and with its
dramatic grand finale quickly
approaching it's the perfect time to
look back on a few of its many
groundbreaking discoveries the Cassini
spacecraft was launched into space on
October 15 1997 with the intended goal
of entering orbit around Saturn to study
the planet and its moons
instead of taking a direct path from
Earth to Saturn Cassini made two
gravitational assist flybys of Venus one
of earth and one final flyby of Jupiter
each of these passes provided a boost to
Cassini's momentum allowing it to make
the long journey to Saturn using less
propellant during its six-month flyby of
Jupiter Cassini was able to capture
about 26,000 images of the gas giant
including the most detailed global color
portrait of the planet on July 1st 2004
Cassini arrived at its destination
thus began the most significant studies
of Saturn and its moons to date while
Cassini wasn't the first craft to visit
Saturn it was the first one intended to
stay there rather than just snap some
photos on the way by because of this the
craft was fitted with some very
specialized equipment such as the
Huygens Lander designed specifically to
be dropped off on Saturn's largest moon
Titan on January 14 2005 the Huygens
probe became the first man-made object
to land on a world in the outer solar
system the furthest from Earth any craft
has ever landed what you're seeing now
is actual footage from the Landers
cameras as it descends toward Titans
surface the thick haze begins to clear
about 45 miles above the surface
revealing some amazing features
scientists hadn't expected such as dark
drainage channels indicating that Titan
once had rushing rivers of liquid
methane the Huygens team thought Titan
might have had a global ocean of
hydrocarbons so they designed the lander
to float and be able to survive a liquid
landing as it turns out there are large
seas on Titan but only at the poles
though scientists suspect that the
wiggins landing area is an ancient lake
bed or floodplain in addition to the
Huygens Lander findings Cassini was able
to gather mountains of useful data
regarding this fascinating moon it
discovered the locations of bodies of
liquid hydrocarbons including one not
far from the Huygens landing site
determined that Titan has active weather
patterns and that much of its surface is
made of frozen water
Cassini helps scientists determine that
Titan is an incredibly promising world
to explore with the thick diverse
atmosphere surrounding the moon and the
abundance of liquid methane and the
potential for liquid water Titan could
very well support forms of life
different than what we see here on earth
but Titans not the only exciting moon
orbiting Saturn over its time in the
Saturnian system Cassini has been able
to make intensive studies of Enceladus
Saturn's sixth largest moon Enceladus
caught scientists attention with its
spectacular plumes which make up most of
the material in Saturn's a ring these
plumes are jettisoned from what are
called cryovolcanoes which erupt water
and other volatiles instead of silicate
rock Cassini has identified over 100 of
these geysers which combined blasts
about 200 kilograms of water ice and
other materials into space every second
some of this water vapor falls back to
the surface as snow while most of it
becomes incorporated into Saturn's ring
these geysers along with the moon's
proximity to Saturn and its other moons
indicate that Enceladus is geologically
active meaning its interior is heated
this is exciting because heat plus water
ice equals water and in this case an
enormous subsurface ocean with a
suspected depth of around 10 kilometers
this discovery was huge the presence of
a salty subsurface ocean heated by
geological activity could mean that
Enceladus has all the necessary
ingredients for life if we take earth as
an example in any place where water
exists there is life even the intensely
hot deep-sea thermal vents are home to
Hardy bacteria and microbes if the same
holds true for elsewhere in the universe
then we could very well find life on
Enceladus there are a handful of plans
to return to the icy moon for further
research and to search for existing life
with one such venture hoping to launch
by 2021 after 20 long years in space
gathering droves of data no one could
have imagined Cassini's life is coming
to an end but it will not go gentle into
that good night
NASA has devised one final glorious
mission for Cassini beginning April 22nd
2017 the Cassini spacecraft will begin a
stay
of dives between Saturn and its rings
something no other craft has ever done
it will make a total of 22 loops
and on the final dive enter Saturn's
atmosphere where it will streak across
the sky and burn away transmitting data
until it goes offline and becomes
forever a part of the planet it's
studied for so many years
Cassini's grand finale is scheduled for
September 15 2017 it seems a shame to
see such a successful craft destroyed
after so long but it's a fitting end and
a necessary one since Cassini is running
out of fuel it's important to take
measures to avoid it crashing into
Enceladus or Titan and contaminating the
moon with microbes and bacteria from
Earth
Cassini discovered the potential for
life on these moons and it seems a
fitting end for the brave little orbiter
to protect them with its dying breath
without Cassini who knows when we would
have discovered the potential for life
right in our backyard
with the wealth of scientific knowledge
we've compiled from the spacecraft's
findings we're more prepared than ever
to make a return trip to the Saturnian
system and explore Titan and Enceladus
more fully lander is equipped with ice
drills buoyant probes even submarines
could be sent to explore the depths of
Titans hydrocarbon lakes or the vast
subsurface oceans of Enceladus we know
there are likely life-changing
discoveries to be made and it's all
thanks to Cassini
[Music]
if you'd like to learn more about
cassini-huygens and their findings check
out the links in the description make
sure to subscribe if you haven't already
and leave a comment down below with your
thoughts on these exciting discoveries
you can watch my other space related
videos by clicking here or watch all my
videos by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video